Kiki ja Post von Google ah danke schön
es gibt eine neue Challenge von Google
und zwar geht es um die suchtrends des
Jahres 2023 in meinem Fall die trending
Lebensmittel ich bin gespannt weil hier
werden jetzt drei der trending
Lebensmittel stehen die die Deutschen in
diesem Jahr gesucht haben in Bezug auf
Rezepten und daraus soll ich mir dann
ein neues Gericht
überlegen hoffentlich ist es nicht ganz
so exotisches oder schwieriges Google
food TRS Challenge 2023 Rezepte mit
Blätterteig aber herzhaft
entspannt das kriege ich hin Rezepte mit
Weißkohl okay und Rezepte mit pfennchel
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich habe glaube ich
noch nie was mit frischem pfännchel
gemacht weil irgendwie hat mich das noch
nie angezogen aber ich find ja cool dass
ich bei solchen challenges auch einfach
immer was Neues kennenler ich bin ganz
ehrlich zu euch ich habe noch keine
wirkliche Idee ich lasse mich jetzt beim
Einkaufen inspirieren und hoffe dann
dass ich ein richtig cooles Gericht
zaubern kann und nicht eins wo man denk
denkt ja sie musste jetzt auf Krampf
diese Zutaten einfügen aber ich lasse
mich jetzt dann gleich im Supermarkt
inspirieren bis gleich Einkauf ist
erledigt und mir ist auch eine Idee
eingefallen mit Blätterteig es gab ja
sogar diesen Trend mit diesem upside
down Blätterteig Rezepten und da finde
ich kann ich den fenill richtig gut mit
integrieren weil es soll ja auch
herzhaft sein übrigens seid ihr so Team
direkt ein Kilo Möhren kaufen die gibt's
auch in großen Säcken oder nur das was
ihr braucht weil wir sind ja ein zwei
Personenhaushalt und ich hole dann
wirklich immer so viel wie ich brauche
dass ich eben nicht weil ich habe das
schon zu oft erlebt dass Leute einfach
Sachen wegschmeißen weil sie direkt zum
größeren Gebinde greifen finde ich
persönlich aber unnötig also es gibt so
oft die Möglichkeit wirklich nur so
einzelne möhen zu kaufen oder hier
penchel übrigens riecht richtig gesund
für mich ist fänchel auch immer so ein
Ding gewesen das kam bei mir so eher zum
Einsatz als pfänchel Tee wenn man
vielleicht mal krank ist oder so aber
damit gekocht habe ich noch nie hier
habe ich den Kohl daraus mache ich
gleich was richtig cooles was alle kennt
und hier auch wieder Zwiebeln einzeln
gekauft um eben nicht zu verschwenden
ich hoffe dass diese Challenge echt gut
meistere ich binmer sehr ehrgeizig bisst
ihr was lass gleich einfach den hamser
probieren der ist nämlich gnadenlos
ehrlich so und wir starten mit dem
Backofen bzw ich habe den Backofen jetzt
einmal schon angemacht und da wird jetzt
der Blätterteig ja gleich erstmal drin
gebacken und während das backt können
wir uns dann ob jetzt verrate ich euch
nicht was das zweite wird um den colslw
Salat kümmern kennen wir ja alle so
dieser typisch amerikanische Kraut Salat
mit Mayo und ah das ist einfach so
lecker den habe ich auch lange nicht
mehr gemacht aber ich mache das jetzt
ich zeige euch das jetzt vom Timing her
wie ich das machen würde nämlich erstmal
ich habe jetzt
tiefkühlblätterteig der ist nämlich ohne
Alkohol da achten ja auch ganz viele
drauf also ihr könntet auch den aus dem
Kühlregal nehmen das ist dieser der dann
so eingerollt ist und den i dann so
aufrollt den könntet ihr auch nehmen
aber ich habe jetzt hier den
tiefgekühlten habe jetzt hier die
Silikonmatte einfach aus dem Grund damit
das gleich nicht so anpappt beim
Auftauen könntet jetzt auch Backpapier
nehmen so und jetzt einfach so 10
Minuten lang liegen lassen so ich glaube
ich mache wisst ihr was das tue ich
wieder zurück in den Tiefkühler weil
Tiefkühlware wenn ihr die wenn ihr da
wirklich achtsam seid und nicht alles
antauen lasst dann habt ihr da nämlich
auch keine Verschwendung das taue ich
jetzt direkt wieder ein damit ich das
für mein nächstes Projekt nutzen kann
und aus den drei ja tiefkühlplatten
mache ich dann sechs upside down fänchel
wie nennt man die eigentlich tat ich
weiß es gar nicht könnt ihr mir mal
reinschreiben wie wir die nennen sollen
wie ihr übrigens außerdem noch
Lebensmittelverschwendung umgehen könnt
ist dass ihr euch aus euren Resten aus
dem Kühlschrank einfach Rezepte ergogeln
könnt also ihr gebt dann quasi ein was
ihr noch da habt und google spuckt euch
dann Inspiration aus und das finde ich
persönlich auch immer genial so ich habe
jetzt hier meine Zutaten für mein KL
Salat ich werde jetzt hier erstmal mich
um meinen Weißkohl kümmern und zwar
werde ich wahrscheinlich ja doch ich
werde den wahrscheinlich erstmal schön
fein in so richtig feine Streifen
schneiden und dann waschen und das ganze
mache ich dann auch noch mit Möhren und
roten Zwiebeln ich finde das rote
Zwiebeln da jetzt einfach richtig gut zu
passen die könntet ihr aber notfalls
auch durch weiße Zwiebeln
[Musik]
ersetzen so ich gebe jetzt schon mal
Kraut und boah wie viel da immer
rauskommt Kraut und Möhren hier einmal
in die Schüssel und als nächstes werde
ich die roten Zwiebeln wie gesagt
richtig schön fein schneiden ich
persönlich mag es halt je feiner desto
besser macht nur die erste dicke
Hautschicht ab und dann ganz ganz fein
schneiden beim Schneiden kann ich euch
auch noch einen Tipp geben also die
Zwiebel erstmal halbieren damit sie euch
nicht so rumwackelt dannit der
Schnittseite nach unten und wenn ich z.B
Nudeln koche oder ganz feine Würfel
haben möchte dann mache ich ja erstmal
hier ein paar Schnitte und dann quer
noch ein paar Schnitte und dann hacke
ich drauf los jetzt in dem Fall möchte
ich es gerne so haben wie die Möhren und
den Kohl daher lasse ich das jetzt so
und schneide hier oben gar nicht und
auch seitlich nicht und dann müsst ihr
quasi die
Fingerkuppen also so dass die Kuppen
hier vorne nach vorne zeigen und die
Fingerspitzen nach innen zeigen also so
diesen Griff und dann fühlt ihr euch mit
dem Messer quasi hier an eurer Hand
entlang und lauft halt nicht Gefahr dass
ihr euch schneidet wenn ihr euch anfangs
unsicher seid dann schneidet das ganz
langsam runter und irgendwann werdet ihr
euch immer sicherer und könnt dann halt
immer schneller
[Musik]
schneiden jetzt kommt ja nur noch das
Mayo Dressing dafür nehmen wir uns
natürlich Mayo und sobald ich das ja
alles ausgeschabt habe kommt da dann
noch achtung nicht erschrecken
Puderzucker mit dazu aber nur ein
bisschen das macht wirklich was mit dem
Geschmack und auch mit der Konsistenz
das alles wird ja dann gleich viel
weicher und dann gebe ich nur noch
Apfelessig Salz und Pfeffer mit dazu und
noch eine letzte Geheimzutat die zeige
ich euch aber gleich bevor jetzt aus
einen
[Musik]
wolkenft ich habe festgestellt dass es
viel einfacher ist mit den Händen
deswegen einfach mit den Händen so ein
bisschen einkneten und so dass irgendwie
alles auch ein bisschen was abbekommt
und jetzt kommt noch mal meine
Geheimzutat und und zwar
Zitronenlimonade es ist wirklich wahr es
passt geschmacklich so gut und es
schmeckt so richtig typisch amerikanisch
dadurch und das lasse ich dann jetzt so
wie es ist einfach ziehen bis unsere
Blätterteig Tarts fertig sind so einmal
den Handschuh abmachen das ganze in den
Kühlschrank geben genau und dann zeige
ich euch was wir mit dem pfänchen
[Musik]
machen so den pentchel habe ich jetzt
schon mal grob angeschnitten also ihr
braucht quasi den strun oben und unten
nicht und ihr habt aber hier noch mal so
ein harten Kern oder noch mal so ein
strung quasi in drin den bekommt ihr
erst weg wenn ihr den pfänchel jetzt in
unserem Fall in so so Scheiben schneidet
so und zwar nehme ich mir mal meine mein
pfänchchen ich schneide hier schon mal
so ein paar Scheiben weg weil wir
brauchen pro Blätterteig dann eine
Scheibe die ist bei mir so ungefähr 4 mm
dick damit ihr euch das zu Hause auch so
ein bisschen vorstellen könnt und dann
seht ihr eben diesen harten und bitteren
Strunk der hier noch ist das ist wie so
ein Dreieck das Schneiden wir dann auch
noch raus und dann ist er auch schon
fertig zu weiter
Verarbeitung so mein Backblech liegt
bereit mit meinem Backpapier oben drüber
und jetzt so punktuell sechs Mal
Olivenöl verteilen da kommen jetzt die
Gewürze ob drauf es ist ja upside down
daher machen wir das jetzt als erstes
und zwar mache ich da jetzt Salz und
Pfeffer mit dazu und zu ffännchel ich
bin ganz ehrlich musste ich auch erstmal
googeln weil ich das ja so selten
zubereite passt am besten Basilikum oder
Tymian und wenn ihr euch unsicher seid
wie gesagt man kann halt auch echt nicht
alles wissen dann einfach googeln was
wozu passt jetzt gebe ich den pfänchel
hier einmal oben drauf und dann kommt
auch schon der Blätterteig da drüber und
dann ist es auch schon fast
[Musik]
fertig
so die Fenchel Tarts waren jetzt bei
200° Ober und Unterhitze für ca 14 bis
16 Minuten im Ofen und jetzt ganz
vorsichtig lösen Bo ich bin so gespannt
wie die ausseht oh sehr schön ich guck
mal welches am schönsten ist oh die sind
alle schön oh das hab jetzt nicht
gesehen gefällt mir sehr sehr gut das
muss jetzt natürlich auch noch schmecken
Leute und ich serviere jetzt das Gericht
und zwar hab ich hier so einen schönen
Teller tue ich zwei von denen drauf so
der KL Salat konnte jetzt auch noch gut
einziehen so das gebe ich jetzt noch mit
dazu oh tolles Menü also ganz ehrlich
rein optisch finde ich das schon mal
sehr farbenfroh gefällt mir sehr sehr
gut so das muss aber jetzt natürlich
auch dem hamser gefallen ich habe jetzt
noch mal ein Tipp für euch ich mag das
ja wenn man dann noch so mit petilie
garniert und Petersilie bewahrt ihr am
besten so auf wie Blumen gib das jetzt
noch mal so auf den Teller und dann
würde ich mal sagen hamser Taste
[Musik]
Test ichd mal interessieren bevor du den
Taste Test machst Hamsa was hättest du
draus gezaubert das sind die Begriffe
das ist ein Brief gewesen das ist Brief
gewesen ich dachte da ist Ire Geld drin
Rezepte mit Blätterteig herzhaft ich
hätte so irgendwas vielleicht
Blätterteig so zybisch was Mama mach so
mit hackfleischwas drinne aber wenn du
jetzt alles drei einbinden MST ach so
okay dann Ciao also ich hätte mit fchen
Problem gehabt glaube ich ich bin
gespannt was du dusus gezaubert hast
okay ich zeig's dir ich habe keine
Ahnung ich weiß nicht was ich gemacht
hätte ganz ehrlich und bitte seid Gos
ehrlich ne ja ich bin immer ehrlich W
schme sage ich mir egal sieht schick aus
das ist ko da ist ein Zwibel
drauf ich habe auch die ganze Zeit
gedacht es könnte auch so eine weiße
Zwiebel sein Weißkohl nein was ist das
Weißkohl hier drin ja was ist denn da
drauf ein Zwiebel nein
hams ernsth was ist den drauf es stand
doch hier drin
Weißkohl was denn ich bin ein Mann ich h
nicht zu fche ist das fche ja ich Ken F
als Pulver desw ich k ich dachte jetzt
so okay fen okay alles klar hier die so
bisschen ich hätte eigentlich jetzt
googeln müssen für das was es ist wie es
aussieht ich hät nicht gewusst ich habe
auch gegoogelt was für Gewürze am besten
zu fänchen passen das brauche ich für
den Salat aber das das and ist Hand ne
das fing auch sei immer schön
ehrlich du weißt ne ist wirklich so ich
back ihm die geilste Torte und er sagt
nee aber mein Kalat der ist eigentlich
bekannt ich bin bekannt für mein Kalat
ja der ist einmalig der ist wirklich
einmalig der ist echt
geil ja man kann nicht so elegant ich
lenke jetzt extra ab damit Jasmin nicht
zeigen kann und ich d zeigen muss hau
mal raus wie schmeckt dir frischer
fennchel krass das schmeckt ähnlich wie
Tee was also so also du hast diesen
fennchel
du hast diesen Nachgeschmack von kennst
wenn du F trinkst ja und der
Nachgeschmack kommt jetzt erst langsam
rein aber ich find es gar nicht so
schlecht erinnert dich halt an te n ist
halt herzft man merkt D herzhaft ist man
schmeckt auch raus ich finde das aber
auch so in Kombi nicht schlecht also der
der Kalat mit dem knusprigen Blätterteig
mit dem pänchel in Verbindung ist
irgendwie total lecker ich hätte nie
gedacht dass ich irg mal fenschel esse
also auuser dem Tee und das auch auf dem
Blätterteig und das auch so gut
harmoniert find mhm das ist echt gut
jetzt habe ich die ganze fen weggegessen
du kannst dir das noch ein allero gönnen
danke für deine Expertise ach so muss
ich jetzt raus aus dem Video der Kamera
nochur ich würde mal sagen ne viel Spaß
ich glaube mir das jetzt ne mach weiter
da gönn dir Leute wisst ihr was das
Beste ist an diesem Tag ich darf jetzt
auch jemanden nominieren für die
Challenge und ich nominiere min von
blondmin min ich bin gespannt was du
draus zauberst du bekommst natürlich
andere Begriffe aber ich werde sofort
einschalten sobald ich sehe dass dein
Video online ist also euch wünsche ich
noch einen wunderschönen Tag und sage
bis zum nächsten mal hier auf kiky
kitchen
[Musik]
tschüss